foreign
[Music]
here we go
all right 2250 in your Pampers
great I feel very I'm in a positional
mood
I feel like playing positionally
let's go D4
okay not sure whether no move sounds uh
okay I just enabled them there we go
Queens gamma declined okay Queen's gamma
decline that's
more more than fine with us let's play
Knight C3
and we have previously in in the
speedrun almost exclusively stuck to the
Carlsbad variation which is also what I
play in my regular Blitz Games
um now Carlsbad is a it's the name of
the variation but it's also the name of
the pawn structure that arises out of
this variation it can also arise in
certain other you know variations on a
theme and it is sort of dictated by the
trade on D5 that's the Carlsbad
variation you can also leave the pawn on
C4 in the main line is Bishop G5 that's
the traditional main line and the
Carlsbad you take on D5 very early
and you release the tension in the
center and you get this structural
imbalance where white has an E Pawn and
black has a seat pawn and everything
else is symmetrical but this ostensibly
small imbalance creates a very
intriguing positional and oftentimes
tactical play in the middle game so now
we play this like a regular Queen's
gamma decline we bring our Bishop to G5
we play E3 we play on the normal Queen's
Gambit moves but a little bit later when
we finish our development you will see
how the Carlsbad structure defines the
course of the game so okay so here
there's a small subtlety I like to start
with Queen C2 in order to prevent the
Bishop from coming out to F5 you can
also play E3 but after E3 Bishop F5 is a
very annoying solid line that I'll talk
a little bit about after the game so
starting with Queen C2 doesn't really
have a downside and it prevents Bishop F
Bishop D6 okay so in the Carlsbad the
bishop usually comes out to E7 but this
is also a viable uh developing Square
although it does doesn't really address
the pin which is why more people like to
put their Bishop on E7
so here after Bishop D3 we were already
threatening the pawn on H7 because the
Knight is pinned to the queen so black
has to play H6 of course we don't give
our Bishop away for no reason we keep it
on H4 and the main choice that white has
in the Carlsbad
is uh concerns where to develop this
Knight
you can develop it to E2 or to F3 and
both moves have clearly defined pluses
and minuses and you can't say that one
of these is better than the other
they're both totally viable Knight F3 is
the more traditional developing Square
for the night but when I played the
Carlsbad I have mostly positioned my
knight on E2 but in this particular
version of the Carol's bed with the
bishop on D6 I actually like to play
Knight F3 and there's a super specific
tactical reason for that that I'll
expand on after the game this is not
essential to your understanding so for
now I'm just gonna play Knight F3 and
I'll spell it out later
but
we are going to play this
very traditionally Knight F3
okay black plays Bishop B6
and okay
Bishop E6 what what can What
observations can we make about this move
well the first thing that
that occurs to me when I when I see it
is that it relinquishes Black's control
over the E5 Square
and I had an entire speedrun game
dedicated to the Pillsbury Knight which
you might remember is a knight that sits
on E5 in Queen's gamma decline positions
and is supported by two pawns the pawn
on D4 and upon that uh arrives at F4 and
the Pillsbury Knight is a very nasty
construction that a lot of players don't
really know how to face and oftentimes
there is no obvious solution
so you might say well let's Castle first
and then let's decide but if we Castle
first then black will already bring the
Knight out to D7 and we might lose our
opportunity uh to entrench that Knight
on E5 so I think we should play this in
a principled way and we should stick the
Knight on E5 while we still have a
chance even before we Castle
and if Knight bd7 then we shove our Pawn
to F4 and the Pillsbury Knight has been
has been born
notice that another drawback of you know
the black dark skirt Bishop not being on
E7 and Bishop takes E5 D5
is not totally out of the question maybe
black and play G5 there
so black will save the piece but he will
create just like
you know gaping weaknesses on the king
side and because we haven't castled yet
we actually might castle queenside if
the circumstances are right if black you
know black hurts himself on the king
side we very well might still Castle
queenside I'm not ruling that out in
ibd7 and F4
and I think the result of the opening
has been pretty successful
so we've gotten the Pillsbury Knight
and now we need to decide which way
we're going to Castle
in these positions you do sometimes
Castle Queen side it's very risky
approach because we don't have a seat
Bond but
uh we definitely shouldn't rule it out
Queen C7 okay
I mean C7 so F5 by the way
it does
technically win the piece but actually
wait let's calculate F5
what happens after F5 if Bishop takes E5
then we can play F takes E6
black has to recapture on E6 we take on
E5
black takes with the queen
then we can Castle Queen side so F5
actually I think does win the piece and
it wins the piece for insufficient
compensation
but the funny thing is I'm also very
enticed by the prospect of just
castleing our position is so good and
the Knight is so stable that we can sort
of procrastinate on playing F5 I don't
think there's all that much that black
can do about it
um but okay in the name of objectivity I
think we should probably consider
trapping the bishop with F5 immediately
yeah it's actually really hard to decide
castles
it leads to a really good position for
white where black has no easy way to get
rid of the Knight but F5 goes after the
bishop and it probably results in us
getting a full minor piece for two for
for only two Pawns
well let's let's see what our opponent
has in mind let's go F5
yeah unfortunately we're losing the
Pillsbury night but we're exchanging it
for a full minor piece so I think that's
a worthy price to pay yeah Bishop takes
C5 and actually here I think it's very
important to start with f takes E6 if we
play D takes E5 then after Queen takes
E5 the pawn on E3 is also hanging with
check
so if you play de5 and fe6 then black is
going to collect three pawns for the
piece and
I mean queen takes E3 is going to come
with check so we should first I think
play F takes E6
Rook takes E6 now we play D5 and after
Queen takes E5 we have earned an
additional Tempo over
uh over overtaking on E5 immediately
so it's a small little Nuance but it's
quite significant and here I think our
best approach is just to say okay we're
gonna give up this Pawn on E3 and at
first sight well then why did we go
after the piece because Black's gonna
get three pawns for the piece it's true
but notice that we have two Bishops we
have not just the bishop air black
simply does not have any Bishops and our
Bishops are sort of crisscrossing the
board I just feel like once the Center
opens up the fact that we have three
minor pieces and the fact that this is a
middle game is going to really really
hurt black the big decision we have to
make is which way are we going to Castle
and because black lacks a minor piece
and black lacks attacking Firepower I
think we'd be fully Justified here just
to cast the Queen's side because this
deploys our Rook a little bit faster
castling kingside I don't know maybe
allows some Knight G4 related ideas the
King on B1 is actually going to be
totally and completely safe
so Castle's Queen side hopefully this
makes
sense from an intuitive perspective
and I assume our opponent is going to
take on E3 this is the first time that
they're thinking
there's also a tricky move d4
I'm just noticing that the bishop on H4
is undefended
um but I'll have to talk about that
afterwards Queen takes a three King B1
so now we get to sort of the second
stage of the game we've won a piece
technically we're not really ahead in
material because black has three pawns
but in the middle game a minor piece is
often worth a lot more than a couple of
Pawns that can change in the end game
that can change if the position is like
locked up but if the position is wide
open like this it should be obvious to
you that the Bishops are superior to
blacks Knights and three Pawns
um notice that I didn't really care that
oh black took with check that did not
even enter into my considerations it
doesn't matter right our King is now
safe on B1 okay
so there is a move here that is
literally just begging to be played
um there's actually a couple of moves
like that there's rokechi one there's
rokechi one which maybe a lot of you are
thinking about but the drawback of Rook
H E1 is that
um well rakeshi one is a good move but
the queen will move back let's say to B6
and then I wouldn't want to trade on E6
and build black up with a better
Superior Pawn Center trading on E6 here
actually helps black and gets black a
pretty impressive Pawn Center the other
move that really comes to mind is Bishop
D3 to F5 which attacks the rook and it
puts pressure on the Knight on t7 the
bishop other Bishop puts pressure on the
other night so Bishop F5 puts black
under a lot of strain the way we can
combine these ideas we can start with
Rook H E1 get the Queen off of our back
and then instead of taking on E6 we can
play Bishop F5 and trade on our terms
with the aim of collecting the e-file
grabbing control of the only open file
which is a very important thing to do
I've shared that piece of advice many
times let's start with the Rook HD1
send the queen away I'm anticipating
Queen B6 maybe Queen C5 uh either one of
these not gonna matter
and
Queen B6 and let's stick the bishop on
F5 why does the pawn Center matter well
again I'll illustrate some variations
after the game but giving black that E6
pun would have been a terrible idea but
Rook D6 is just self-destruction
our opponent is trying to keep as many
pieces on the board as possible but he's
just blind to the dangers I mean the
first thing I see when I look at this
move the Rook is trap I mean The Rook is
trapped can we attack it well it's in
our dark Square do we have a dark
squared Bishop we do we can play Bishop
G3 in the rookus tracks that's it the
game is over
of course nothing wrong with the move
rookie seven that's probably the move I
would play if we didn't have Bishop G3
but we do and we win the rook and we win
the game
yeah and our opponents just played way
too quickly in the middle game
yeah this is okay Queen C5
but this is a good opportunity to
practice being precise which a lot of
people
really need a lot of work on
so a lot of people just oh yeah let's
say gun D6 of course nothing wrong with
taking the Rook will be up a rook the
game will not be over black will still
have three pawns we will still have to
demonstrate some technique but let's try
to be clinical because that's what
somebody at a you know at this level
would do and we have a better move than
Bishop takes D6 when I see Queen C5 I'm
noticing
that the Queens are now aligned with
each other
and that creates the possibility for
tactics but not just that it also
creates the possibility for a queen
trade The Rook isn't going anywhere
right The Rook is already trapped we
don't need to take it immediately as
long as we keep our two Bishops in place
The Rook on D6 ain't going anywhere so
the move I'm thinking about is actually
Knight C3 to E2 dropping the Knight back
offering a queen trade but if the Queens
are traded then black is even gonna have
a hard time getting anything for that
Rook
the other really good move here is
somebody's proposed Knight C3 takes B5
same exact idea if like the trade on C2
occurs then we not only trade Queens
which is good because we'll be upper
Rook but we also win the pawn on B5 so I
think Knight takes B5 is maybe even the
best move
and we are going to go for it I takes B5
great move
yeah even Knight E4 probably was decent
but
this is this is super clinical
and I think
our opponent is going to resign shortly
yeah now he's now he's thinking but it's
it's a little too late
yeah hopefully everybody sees the point
of this move if Queen takes B5
then we dis attach the queen from the
rook and we play Bishop takes D6 we're
up a full Rook
and then you might be like well what but
then we didn't get a chance to trade
Queens but it doesn't matter I mean look
at Black's knights in that resulting
position I actually would want to keep
the Queens on the board here
I think it's faster for us to win by
keeping the Queens on the board and
resigns yeah bit of a lackluster game
but nonetheless couple of remarks
so
yeah this is the Carlsbad C takes D5
I definitely have
I think more than one Speed Run game
in the Carlsbad
yeah and and already after like C6 Queen
C2 Bishop D6 I was getting hopeful
because Bishop D6 is has long been
considered an inaccurate developing
Square
for for the bishop
um it's long been considered an
inaccurate developing score for the
bishop
usually in the Carlsbad you see
blackplay Bishop E7 this is the main
line
and then white plays E3
castles Bishop D3 and ibd7
and here once again as as we did in the
game we have a choice between developing
to F3 and developing to E2 and I could
not possibly explain all the
complexities of the Carlsbad and like
one analysis session
so I'll restrict myself with just a
couple of General points
most of the time that I've played this
with white I've gone Knight G2 and the
main idea of developing the Knight to E2
over F3 is that you leave
the F Pawn free
now why is that important because there
is a traditional plan in the Knight G2
carols but where white goes F3 and E4
it's as simple as that white wants to
steamroll Black off the board by
eventually pushing the pawn to E5 and
then following up with F4
I mean there's like a ton of games you
can see especially games played decades
ago when
people with black just did hadn't fully
developed how to achieve counter play
against this you can see some like
incredibly one-sided
games in the Carlsbad I think there's a
famous Batman akaris game
if memory serves me right that I can try
to unearth I had a game in this line
that was
kind of straightforward in that regard
let me see if I can find the Bob in the
game and even if you don't play like 1d4
I think it's generally
very a very good idea to just educate
yourself on this kind of stuff
is you never know
when you can benefit from ideas that you
learned in another opening
so they reached the Carlsbad here via
the nimsovich
but okay yeah like Karis doesn't play
the names of it she transposes the
Queen's gamma declined
trade Bishop G5
okay so here you can see Kara's plays
Bishop E7 as is traditional
and you get basically the same position
Karis delays C6 for a bit and Knight G2
back in bhavanick's day this was not
quite as common so Keras didn't really
know how to respond to this
traditionally Knight f8
there's that C6 move and batmanic goes
for kb1
so he a little bit of misdirection he
makes Karis think that he's preparing
the classic minority attack B4 B5 which
is the like most typical plan in these
positions it's the minority attack where
you would want to advance the pawn to B5
in order to break down Black's Queen
Side Pawn chain that's the traditional
positional plan but suddenly after Karis
plays Bishop to D6 kind of like our
opponent but how many goes King H1
tactical alertness B4 runs into this
classic idea Bishop H2 and Knight G4
so bhavanick doesn't miss the tactic
King H1 is a very ingenious defense
because you might say wait black can
still take
but of course this isn't a check anymore
so white can start by eliminating the
Knight
severing the the mechanism and then
taking the bishop
so Knight G6 by Keras and there's F3 by
Bob vinic and watch how quickly
everything
just comes to a head in the center first
he goes rookie one he abandons the old
plan and instead focuses on preparing E4
Keras just kind of just starts
floundering about Knight F6 to D7 it's a
mistake
because after the trade Bobby Nick's
Night comes out to a very nice Square
the queen slides over to F2 very
important move because if you had gone
E4 immediately common problem in the
Carlsbad you're going to lose the pawn
on D4 so notice how he puts the queen on
F2 so that it protects the D4 Pawn after
he plays E4 sometimes the dark squared
Bishop fulfills this role I'll show you
one of my games where instead of a queen
enough to you put a bishop on F2 but
precisely for the same reason Bishop B6
first he sticks the Knight on F5 to
induce a favorable trade and after Queen
B6 bang it's time for E4
and watch how quickly Black's position
just collapses so they trade Keras says
well I'm going to try to attack White
Center but Batman just keeps advancing
E5 and as is very common when you play
E5 you create a nice little pathway for
your knight to a beautiful outpost on D6
and you might say well but doesn't black
also have an outpost on D5 of course he
does but just look at the way that
White's pieces are beautifully
coordinated on the enf files all of them
aiming in the general direction of of
Black's King on the F7 pawn and these
things they don't just you know happen
by accident
Knight D6 Kara says I gotta bring
everything back and now Bishop E4 by
bombonic Paving the way for the Knight
to jump into F5
the queen comes into the attack
threatening Checkmate inducing another
weakness now Bobby Nick decides to open
the C file and occupy it with his Rook
and this is just a means to an end Keras
has to stay connected to the Rook on E7
why is it a means to an end because now
he lifts The Rook up to C3 in order to
lift it to H3 and just Checkmate wax
King rook f8 and now a little tactics to
end the game Knight F5 anyway
if gf5 then Rook G3 check Knight G7 and
queen F6 with unstoppable checkmate
so Karis tries to give up an exchange
bubbling says no thank you tight H6
check Queen F6 rook cf3 and F7 is now
Under Fire and cannot be defended the
Knight the queen and both of the Rooks
are all attacking F7 you got four
attackers three Defenders and you cannot
add another Defender Karis loses the
pawn and shortly thereafter he loses the
game so this is a classic game and it's
a sort of nice advertisement for the
Knight G2 Carlsbad
now since this game was played in 1952
theory has advanced a lot and so you
normally don't see Grandmasters of the
black pieces losing quite like this but
I was able to win a nice game
um some some years ago
in the Carlsbad
and I kind of won in similar fashion not
nearly as smoothly but it was kind of a
similar Arc of the game
let me pull this up
and I was playing a GM from Argentina
who's pretty old but very experienced
player
and we got the same
exactly the same move order same
position
here he plays C6 almost immediately and
he plays a more modern
uh variation of blackplay's A6
and very often like blacks more modern
idea involves counter striking on the
queen side black dishes just sit around
and wait for white to play F3 and E4
black prepares a very quick B7 B5 and
sometimes black even plays C5 like
boardnik like Nicola Bortnick although
C5 runs the risk of creating an iqp
structure which is favorable for white
because the Knight on E2 also controls
the square in front of the pawn so
he plays A6 which is one of the
fashionable moves Rook 8 D1 and F3 there
we go we're starting to prepare E4 and
notice that after Bishop E6 Bishop H4
Rook C8 black or I tuck my Bishop away
on F2
much like Batman X Queen now it's the
bishop that's going to over protect D4
gampora plays G6 and King H1 very
important move if you play E4
immediately after d e f e black has this
very nasty move Knight G4 and either you
have to give away your very valuable
dark squared bishop or you get forked on
E3 the point of King H1 is that after
you play E4 it takes the sting out of
Knight G4 because the bishop can drop
back to G1
B5 and just A3 preventing and stopping
Black's Queen side expansion
and first I played Knight F4 so notice
that I'm not hurrying with E4 I'm making
all the improving moves first but then I
finally struck in with E4
and the attack just went super fast
Bishop P3 occupying the square left
behind by the pawn Knight C2
accumulating pieces trade on E6 and E5
and this is another a very important
idea you advance the pawn to E5 and if
there is a black Pawn on G6 your idea is
just to go F4 and F5 and smash through
leaking side which is exactly what
happens my opponent tries to create some
counter play but I didn't care F4
and after Bishop G7 I I decided to play
the move B3 to force the Knight off of
C4 little Pawn sack and now here comes
F5 bang just smashing through black
skiing side Knight comes out to F4 and
already the game is over
because I've shown this game before by
the way on stream if F takes E5 then 96
and first of all the Knight on A3 is
saying but also you can play Bishop
takes F5 with the skewer
so black has to move the bishop back and
now E6 is the crusher again Bishop takes
E6 96 and you can have your pick between
the Knight on the pawn
and after Bishop G6 we continue
exploding Black's King side with G4
F takes G4 is forced otherwise GF and
black is dead lost
take take
and now send the queen over to attack
it takes G4 and after Bishop F7 he
resigned because
King f8 the pretty win that I saw was
Bishop E3 and whatever black does Bishop
comes to H6
with an immediate win because
this is just Checkmate so
yeah so this is a nice another nice
Carlsbad game of course I could show you
games where black one and where the you
know Central attack misfired for white
this is far from a refutation of the
Queen's gametic line but I think it's
one of the most underrated openings
especially for you know D4 players in
the 2000 2200 range almost everybody
tends to go for like the traditional
Main Line Bishop G5 or people play the
Catalan and stuff but Carlsbad hasn't
gotten enough love I think especially
from the white side because the plans
are easy to learn and Black's counter
play is is hard to attain if you're not
a specialist
so we go back to the game
all right so in the game black played
this of course a little bit differently
with the bishop on D6 but it didn't
change the way that we
developed oh it did actually change the
way we developed our pieces I decided to
play Knight F3
and the main reason for that is that
Knight G2 while totally viable runs into
Knight bd7
and the problem is that after White
Castles black has
to my knowledge this annoying idea of
Bishop takes H2 and Knight G4 check and
I wasn't totally sure what the
evaluation of this
speculative but potentially very
dangerous idea is
um
now you might look at this and say well
but the king can move up and it can
defend the bishop true
but after King let's say King H3 black
can just play Knight df6 and suddenly
the King has been
has been drawn into this uh it's caught
on the crossfire it can't go back to H2
there's discoveries there's G5 and this
is just a very messy position same goes
for King G3 black can go Knight df6
so Knight H5 is is a very dangerous
threat and if white takes it after Queen
takes F6 the king is again it's just
stuck in the middle of all these
attacking pieces much like the Greek
gift sacrifice
so
yeah so I was annoyed by this idea
and of course you can play H3
to prevent Bishop takes H2 from existing
but if you play H3 then later on when
you play F3 you're gonna create a pretty
big hole on on G3 so that's a move you
normally want to avoid if you're
preparing the F3 E4 plan in the Carlsbad
so for that reason I decided to play
more traditionally with Knight F3
okay Bishop E6 I think is fine after 95
this is where I think black our opponent
started to go wrong
I think Knight bd7 is very Cooperative
but after F4 yeah and after F4 I already
think black is in trouble because F5 is
a big threat
there's just no way no good way to deal
with this Knight
I think what black had to do was try to
undermine this Knight at all costs and
to do it immediately like black cannot
delay because if white plays F4 and the
Knight is entrenched then the the ship
has sailed so what's the move
that tries to undermine the Pillsbury
Knight well G5 doesn't G5 just makes it
worse because after Bishop G3 you've
created a permanent and massive weakness
on the king side which I can then attack
with H4 the move is C5 yeah C5 you you
try to get at the root of the Knight you
go C5 and the other benefit of this move
is that it opens up the C6 Square for
the Knight
so let's say White Castle's King side
here I think the position is probably
about equal maybe a tiny bit better for
white but black can play CDE and Knight
C6 and this has forced the nitrate
because if white plays F4 we drop one of
the anchors of the Pillsbury Knight
that's not uh you know that's that's
that's unthinkable
and of course white can play Knight
takes C6 and now we get this sort of
hanging Pawn structure which I think the
position is probably about balanced
maybe white is a tiny bit better the
pawn on C6 is a little bit of a weakness
and you can try to attack it by well you
can try to blockade it by getting the
Knight around to C5 which is another
very traditional way to fight that pawn
so if I had to pick a side here I'd pick
white but compared to the game this is
so much so much more palatable for black
after C5 you could also Castle queenside
and this just leads to a very sharp
position but I I wouldn't have gone for
this this to me Queen A5 like the C file
is open black can still play Knight C6
and if you train now the B file is open
black can put a rook on V8 White's
attack is a lot less uh you know
just a lot less fast in this in this
case so in the event of C5 we would have
castled kingside
um
but in any case uh Knight p87 F4 and
queen C7 of course gives up the piece I
am looking with the engine what's
interesting is that F5 actually is
well it's saying it's much better but
inaccurate it actually is giving Castle
short as the best move so maybe we
should have just been patient and and
see what happened because black has like
literally no defense to F5 the move that
made me avoid castles is actually Knight
D7 f8
and here of course the first thing that
you probably see is that white can play
Bishop takes F6 and permanently ruin the
king Side Pawn structure but the
downside is that the Knight now has to
evacuate E5
so obviously white is much better here
you could swing the queen from F2 to H4
and attack black squeak pawns the bishop
is aiming at the king it's like plus 1.8
here totally reasonable
um
so maybe this was a more uh
surgical continuation
ZX consumed asks Rook F3 and said okay
so first of all Rook F3 instead of
Knight F3 has been proposed I don't know
if it's worth sacrificing the Knight
though I I don't doubt that white has
tremendous compensation maybe you can
even mate black with some sort of Queen
E2 Queen H5 maneuver but this has to be
calculated very carefully
but very very much possible that this is
in fact the best way to play like Queen
E2 and queen H5 is already a huge threat
so definitely yeah Rook F3 needs to be
calculated
there was another question if we rewind
a little bit earlier after C5
why not Bishop F oh after C5 F4
c d e d Knight C6 why not Bishop F2
defending the punt yeah this is fine but
I don't want to allow Knight before and
one of the drawbacks of the Pillsbury
Knight is that of course you're creating
a weak Square on e4 oftentimes that
square on e4 is well protected by the
minor pieces so it doesn't really show
up on the surface but if the bishop is
eliminated then black can stick a knight
on e4 and White's position starts
collapsing in the blink of an eye
so for example like Queen let's say
queen E2
trade already black and play the move
94.
and you might say well this just
blunders upon but don't miss the forest
for the trees in evacuating the Knight
out of F6 black has paved the way for F6
Pawn F6 and white is busted white just
loses the net E5 if we move the Knight
back we haven't even castled yet so
moving the bishop who actually wins the
queen
um I think 95 is still a good move I
think it's a very testing move
I think it's a testing move
um and I think it forces black to play
very accurately so I I stand by the fact
that 95 is is a great move
and the way it happened we played F5
and here I think another mistake
by black to give away the dark scored
Bishop
the fact is just giving away both
Bishops leads to a situation where it's
very hard to contain White's initiative
I think black's Last Chance was probably
to play Knight takes C5 and give the
piece up like this
and here black is not even aiming to get
all three pawns back but at least black
keeps the dark squared Bishop which is
exerting its influence over both sides
of the board and here I think the game
continues
I was planning to still Castle queenside
but
okay maybe black can try something like
B5
white is definitely should we should be
winning with best play but I think this
is a little bit more double-edged with
black maintaining the dark Square Bishop
after Bishop E5 again important subtlety
we start with f takes E6 if we had
started with DE after Queen takes C5 Fe
there's Queen takes E3 check which is an
unnecessary thing to allow still good
for white after Queen E2 but this trades
queens and as we already discussed we
actually don't really want to trade
Queens here unless we have to
okay
so after take C6 now the Knight is
attacked and the bishop is attacked so
black has to give up a piece rookie 60e
Queen E5 and another important moment I
think a lot of people here and you guys
might think oh well of course we Castle
but I think a lot of people would be
tempted to play Bishop F2 or like Knight
D1 because in my experience like tons of
people are kind of servants to their
Pawns and and you don't think about
giving away a pond like this in the
center but 91 is a good example of
you know
to looking at the position in a kind of
nearsighted manner because you're
you're defending upon that not only does
it need to be defended but you're making
your pieces passive as a result and
you're giving black a potential
initiative and if Bishop F2 then maybe
you're allowing D4 and all of this is
totally unnecessary for the small price
of another Pawn you can open up the
e-file to your favor even though
currently black is the one controlling
it that's not sustainable we're gonna
play rookie one to chase the queen away
and Bishop F5 to chase The Rook away so
the control of the e-file is going to
change hands and we have ensured
long-term safety of our King so we can
focus on exploiting our extra piece
okay B5 makes matters worse because it
doesn't address the issue of rookie one
at all and after Queen C B6 Bishop F5 I
think it's already pretty much lost but
the last chance for black of course is
to play Rook takes C1 and just keep
playing I don't know takes Queen D4 or
something and maybe A5 but okay the
position is the position is is terrible
we can play G4 G5 black is totally
paralyzed here okay Rook D6 Bishop G3 is
is game over immediately
Queen C5 and Knight takes B5 is indeed
the best move
uh this is the most the most clinical if
C takes B5 then we first take the queen
and then we take the full Rook we win
The Rook
um question by Sergio sure would
wouldn't D4
wouldn't D4 would have been good instead
of taking with the queen
let's see I'm not sure
oh D4 here no but D4 here IA I did
mention this move this is a trap you
don't want to play Ed because you drop
the bishop on H4 loose pieces drop off
but white has many ways to circumvent
this
the absolute simplest is to first play
Bishop takes F6
and if Knight takes F6 then we can very
safely take on D4 and by can't even
recapture because of Bishop H7 winning
the queen
so this would be one way to address it
but nothing wrong with just dropping the
Knight back to E2 and yeah you're
allowing a pawn to get to E3 big deal
it's blockaded by the Knight and we can
go Rook H to F1 go Rook F5 or Bishop F5
now we have the D file again black just
cannot coordinate and control all of the
key squares with these two incredibly
lame Knights on D7 and F6
so that um
maybe still would have been the best
defensive resource D4
the the engine says Knight G4 uh gave
the most practical chances
Bishop G3 and now not Queen takes C3 but
actually Knight takes E3
counter-attacking
um
the Queen Bishop takes E5 Knight takes
C2 now we have the Desperado move Bishop
takes G7
Knight drops back to E3 attacking The
Rook this is the engine line Bishop D4
and you actually do give away an
exchange and you get two Bishops for The
Rook but these are two monster Bishops
why it's got control over the center and
here white is significantly better but
maybe not completely winning
also like plus 1.5 so after Knight G4
maybe black maintained uh reasonable
defensive chances Queen takes E3
actually seems to be a serious mistake
um because now the queen is in an
incredible incredibly vulnerable spot
get the Rook back to E1 Bishop F5
and Bishop G3 to trap the rook and win
the game
and that's all that I have to say yeah
that was a pretty
to be honest a pretty lackluster game
but I'm still gonna put this up on
YouTube and I I still think there's
utility to be derived from it
I'm also going to do an analysis of
fabby's best game from the US
championship
and put that up as well so
you have a lot to look forward to
but let's pause here for today guys this
has been a three plus hours so I think
that's a good
spot to end
when will I start a new spin I don't
know if I will start a new speed run
when we hit 2300
we're like 18 points away
I will retire this speedrun
and then
we'll probably start a new one at some
point but I don't know when that'll be
and I don't you know I don't know which
direction I'm going to take YouTube in
all right take care everybody thanks for
hanging out
[Music]